Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go ahead and wrap up animating our texture.
So let's get started. So in Unreal, we have our scene set up here. So we have a specular,
we have a little bit of exaggeration, a little bit of wave movement. Now, again, we can dumb
this down for the opacity. So if we need this to be a little bit lighter, we can go from
and we can do this also in the instance material. As we talked about that concept, we can do
0.2 if we wanted to. It's a little bit more subtle. And that actually might work pretty
well. All right, so let's add or finish up the rest of this. And then what we can do
for fun is add that normal map of that wave when we just made. Now, I didn't give this
to you in the class, but you're more than welcome to make your own normal, whatever you want,
and put it in. And we're going to look at the different ways you can do that. So first
up, let's go ahead and add our normal. And we're going to keep it pretty straightforward.
We're not going to get into inverting things and making sure that we can do so if we wanted.
We're going to keep things pretty simple, where we're just going to layer the normals
on top each other. And one of the ways to do that, again, we can use the blend angle.
And you'll see it's called blend angle corrected normals. And again, this guy allows us to
be able to have two normals on top of each other. And it honors them so they don't get
too muddled, they actually blend correctly. And there's no distortion between them. Now,
it does a pretty darn good job of keeping that from getting too distorted. And I actually
like it pretty well. It's pretty great. I'm going to keep my finger on, I'm going to click
on the pattern out here, and do control D and duplicate that what we already have. And
we're going to pull up the we need the raindrop normals. Now, if we go back to raindrops,
you'll see that I already have a normal built for you. And we can pull that right into our
scene. So let's pull that normal right here. And we can connect our painter to it. And
then we can put this into our additional normal. And this is the rock normal, and we can make
that our base normal. And then we can set that right into our scene. Now, if we wanted
to add even more, we can bring in that wave normal that I made. And if we go back up into
step five, you'll see that wave one. Now I made this on my own, you do not have access
to this one, you can simply take him into Photoshop, make a black layer, make him white,
and convert him to a normal. So I'm going to drag him into the scene, I'm just showing
you what you can do if you wanted to stack these. And I can keep these things a little
bit more simple with a multiply. Now, you do want to be careful when doing this, because
if I just kept that as a multiply, the problem we can run into is where our control how strong
that normal is is going to come through. So we would have to go in here and use a lurp
again. And that can be very helpful. So we'll grab this normal put an A channel, put him
into the B channel. And then we can try to go in here and use air, create a scalar parameter.
And we can control that way. Now it's going to overall kind of mute things. So you got
to be careful with that. So another way you can do it is we can bring this into this particular
one into a multiply. And in that multiply, then make a scalar parameter and call this
wave normal amount. Got to be able to type that. There you go. So we can even call it
large wave if you want to do we'll just leave it like wait for now, put it into the B channel,
put this in the A channel, then create a multiply and bring it into here. And that's going to
be a little bit more macro control versus micro. Now I like having this little micro
control because then I can choose and isolate an effect. Maybe I don't like this as much.
Maybe I like this a bit more. And I want this to be muted compared to it. And that can be
helpful. And then now we can pull this right into our normal and see what we get. And you
can see we get kind of it's a little dark, right? So we are multiplying pretty heavily
on here. If it helps, we can go in here and keep our finger the L key and change our lighting.
So it's a little less harsh. You can see the wave effect we got going on when light hits
at a certain way. So we're like, hmm, that waves a little strong. So we'll go in here
with this wave amount. And actually, he's zero right now, let's put one and see what
you get. That's much better. I thought he was already active. There we go. That looks
much better. It is dark because they were overall multiplying a zero, which was given
us like kind of darkness. Actually works pretty well. That's actually not bad. So again,
you can experiment with this any way that you want. We have our drips going through
here and overall kind of wave, you don't necessarily have to have drips with wave. But that's up
to you. So let's go ahead and wrap things up. So a few more things we need to do. Let's
go ahead and kind of do a little bit of the same concept, but a little more simplistic
without obviously the corrective blend, we're going to get these two guys into play and
one of them being the AO and one of them being the cavity. There's the AO, there's a cavity.
And you can determine how you want to stack these, but we can go ahead and move this out
of the way for a second. I'm going to keep my finger the M key and we'll multiply. And
we'll have these guys kind of magnify each other. And what I mean by that is you get
a higher contrast with both of them together and you can see that change here as we zoom
in. So you can get a stronger if you're if you're noticing your AO is not as strong as
you need, but mega scans you notice gave you gave you a cavity map to you can combine them
via the multiply. That's pretty convenient. So let's go and grab the raindrops that we
need. So we need some raindrops that are we able to work well with ours. So let's see,
did I bring in the AO raindrops? Maybe I didn't. Let's go and grab those. And let's pull
this in. And you don't necessarily have to do this last step. But that is up to you how
you want things how strong you want them to be. If you want the raindrops to look like
they have a little bit of a shadow, you can maybe go this route. I'm going to go ahead
and keep my finger on control D at the same time and keep my cursor at the area I want
it and we'll duplicate what we need. Oops, I grabbed the wrong thing. Let's go back to
Panor is what I meant to do. Control D. We're going to duplicate him over here. And we're
going to move that right into the raindrops, pull that in. And then we'll move and make
we'll make one more multiply, give me a finger the M key left click and pull a string into
the B channel and then pull this texture sample on a channel. And then from here, we can take
this into the AO ambient occlusion. And you can highlight some of the dark regions of your
texture and your object. Pretty sweet. We made some moving water texture. And again,
it's up to you if we in this case, we don't really need the metallic. But if you wanted
to exaggerate things a little more, you could put the metallic in there. You just got to
be careful because you know, the stone isn't really metal. And it may end up being way
too reflective. It may look like 10. So let's disconnect that real quick, you can see the
difference. And it's a little more realistic without it. But I left it in our scene. So
you can do a comparable if you wanted to. So that's it for animating the materials. Hope
you enjoyed that part of the lecture. And the next video, we're going to talk about you
working with alphas and bringing things such as torn clothes into a scene and some of the
nodes and options we have for that. Thanks again.